(audience cheering)
- Thank you for coming by.
- Hello, Clarkson.
- We were literally
working together yesterday on "The Voice."
- Literally, all the time, every day.
- [Kelly] And I was like,
"See you tomorrow buddy."
- See you tomorrow.
- It's nice to have new
coaches on "The Voice,"
and y'all are so good, you and Chance.
I do love in that clip, that
Chance thought it was so funny
that you were turning
Blake's chair around,
as you turned his around.
- Yeah, just like, "What's going on?"
- [Kelly] That was awesome.
- And I just headbutted yours.
- I love too though,
that you jumped right
into giving Shelton crap.
- [Niall] Oh yeah.
- I love it.
- No, for sure.
I love winding him up.
- Because you're a country boy,
like we're a country people too,
and so it was like really nice
that you came in and like just
felt right at home with that.
- Wind the old man up.
- Made me feel really good.
I was like, I have a team.
- You're a pro at that.
- I am. Well practice makes perfect.
So you've definitely perfected
though the Blake impression.
We've done interviews for the show and he,
I want you to just, how
do you talk like Blake?
- Well the other day, they told me
I sounded like "Forrest Gump."
- No you don't.
He was saying that. He's dumb.
- This is my last season on "The Voice."
(audience cheering)
I want you to be on my team
and I hate Kelly Clarkson.
That's what it usually sounds like.
- About sums it up.
Oh, do you remember the
first time that you ever,
I don't know, you were singing
and somebody kind of was like,
"Wait, you're like really good at that?"
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Because you were
young on "X Factor," right?
- Yeah, I was like 16 on the show.
That's crazy when I think about it.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Look at you,
little baby. Baby Niall.
(audience cheering)
- It's baby Niall. I love baby Niall.
He couldn't even drive or
maybe you could, I don't know.
- God, he was terrible.
- No, he was awesome.
- So yeah, no, I guess it was kinda like,
I remember one time, my
aunt lives in New York
and she would come over
to Ireland every summer
with her kids, and we'd
like take little road trips
around Ireland, and I remember like,
I dunno why she's thought
this, but I was singing,
♪ I've got friends in low places ♪
and I started singing it,
and for some reason she
thought I was the radio.
- Oh my gosh.
- She thought like it was on the radio
and she thought I was the radio.
- That would've given
me so much confidence.
- Which is crazy 'cause
I hadn't even hit puberty
and I still sounded like Garth Brooks.
Yeah, that was nuts.
And I remember like my teacher at school
that was like running the choir,
she kind of took me under her
wing and told me I was decent.
So then it kind of
took, yeah, that was it.
- Me too, that was kind of my thing too.
Yeah, just a choir kid. Yeah.
- School plays and all that stuff.
- Yeah. Okay, wait, speaking
of young Niall though,
I wanna see that, let's
start at this photo.
(audience cheering)
First of all, I love that you look like
you're selling insurance
at the age of two.
You were in a full on suit, kind of like.
Look at that cardigan. I love it.
- I'm Niall from "State Farm."
- It's amazing.
You love cardigans now though.
I love your style by the way.
- Thank you.
- I say it every time you show up.
- You do actually, yeah.
- You look so cool like
every time you show up.
- Thanks.
- How many cardigans do you own?
- This is why I love
working with her by the way.
- No, he does. He looks so cool.
He walks out of the room
and I'm just like, what?
Like it just, yeah, you're
just like screaming.
It's annoying.
But how many cardigans do you own?
- A lot.
I didn't realize how many I'd like owned
until my fans started
pointing it out to me.
We wanna see your cardigan collection
'cause you clearly have a lot.
- When they ask that,
that means you definitely have a lot.
- Yeah, honestly I didn't realize it.
You know, it's that time
of the year, it's winter,
you're kind of always just
like, just throw it on.
And then I opened up the closet
and had a look and I was
like, "Oh, I have a lot."
- I think we have a video
of your card in collection.
So I wanna show this.
- I only have like one, two, three.
7,645 million.
God I love cardigans.
(audience cheering)
- I love how you said "tree."
One. Two. Tree.
- Yeah, I remember saying that and going,
"Oh, I'm gonna get ripped for that one."
The old Irish accent. Tree.
Yeah. I've tried to like
start pronouncing my TH.
- Don't do it.
- [Niall] THs. THs.
- [Kelly] THs. Work on that.
So your big break
obviously was on "X Factor"
and I came up on "Idols."
So you came up with a group,
which I think is cool.
I think, I was, we do know of them,
but no, I just, I was very
lonely, like off the top.
Like I was 19, a little
older whenever I started,
but like I was very lonely
and I think that must have been cool like
that you had like buddies to lean on
and like do y'all still have that?
Do you have that? Like, we have a group.
Well we have a group text
we can't tell anyone about.
But we have a group text like
with "The Voice" coaches,
but like, but do y'all
still, do you have that?
Do you have that kind of camaraderie?
I just, I would love that.
- Yeah, no. we were so,
especially on the show,
we were so lucky.
Like 'cause you would
see all the other artists
melting all the time over everything.
We were just 16, 17, 18,
19, whatever we were.
(audience cheering)
- But that's like kinda awesome
that you had people to lean on.
I just, I would've loved that.
- It was so fun. Definitely.
I'd do it again.
That's why I'm doing "The Voice."
- I would do it. I would it again too.
I love doing "The Voice," for that reason.
It is actually cool.
Full circle moment that you get to say
I've been in your, I don't like that
that's your pitch though,
'cause that's my pitch.
- Yeah, she uses the like,
"I came from a show like this,"
and then I was like, "Wait,
let see what I've got."
- I was like, "Damn it."
- Me too.
But yeah, no, we, of course,
we speak constantly so it's...
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- Good little thing to have.
- Yeah, I was like, I always
looked at groups like that
and I'm like "Ah, that
would've been cool."
To just have someone to...
- You won on your own.
- It's okay.
No, this is the greatest thing.
- This is so funny about that.
- Wait, so we're doing
a skit for "The Voice."
I thought "One Direction" won.
(audience laughing)
I mean, 'cause you did in life.
You go, "Actually we came in third,"
and I was like, "What?"
I was like, cause I didn't watch,
I just like, knew that's
where you came from.
but like, congratulations.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- [Kelly] They killed it.
So you've just released, I'm
not kidding, I love this song.
And this is, it's been three
years, like a few years.
- Yeah. Literally.
- "Heaven" is the new single.
(audience cheering)
It's so good, man.
I gave him crap because
the other day I was like
"I've only heard a snippet and I love it."
And so finally I got to hear it today.
It's so good.
- Thank you.
- Like, I mean, did you write like
with your normal writing partners
or like producers that you work with?
Or is this a new team?
- I always try and keep it small.
If it's not broke, don't
fix it, kind of guy.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- You're the same.
- Yeah, I am the same. Yeah.
- We literally had this
conversation yesterday.
- [Kelly] Yes, we did.
- And I think that's important
and we just kind of locked ourselves,
we went over to Joshua Tree for a week.
We were kind of going around,
I did lots of stuff at home on my own.
All the ballads were done at
home basically during lockdown.
And then when it came to
all the up tempo post stuff,
I was like, "Right, we
need to like leave LA."
So we went out into Joshua
Tree, rented an AirBnB,
set up a studio there, had a few beers,
wrote whenever we want, had
some food, swim in the pool,
write a song in the pool,
all that kind of stuff.
And then it was a 1:00 AM
just before we went to bed,
I just started playing
the chords of the song
and started going, "La da da da."
- It's so catchy, "Where this could go."
- And then is it was,
that's where it came from.
I thought I was going to
bed and then I wasn't,
and we have this now.
- What an inspiring place.
Everybody's gonna run there now to write.
It's just such a killer song.
It's such a fresh sound.
Like I just thought it was,
I love your first stuff like,
but I think this is like
it's just like an evolution
I feel like musically.
Do you feel like that?
- Yeah, for sure.
I think, I think we look at
like those like late teens,
early twenties as big formative years.
But I didn't realize how
formative 25 to 30 is.
You know, like a lot goes on in your life.
Things change.
We had a pandemic, that's
gonna change things up.
So you do a lot more
thinking about everything.
So that's just as you change,
your music changes with it,
and I'm sure you're the same like.
- Absolutely, yeah life
definitely inspires the art.